when you think of the op in cs go
chances are
a few names come to mind there's the
cheery rosy cheeked chosen one zywoo
well they're anticipating banana from
the looks if it got over over here it's
gonna be with it rings out first
he's had enough he's gonna keep going
through it he doesn't really care again
get him out of here
or maybe you think of the ever iconic op
magician
kenny s the important round right here
they need a bit they need to go big and
kenny's gonna go head peak in a second
man and he gets the flick on his
lightning fast it could also be that
when you think of the big green you
think of its most decorated wielder to
date
big daddy device devices had a really
rough game flashed he's gonna get that
shot and it has to feel a little bit
going out middle of the air to take down
alex and now they're pushing oh
really gonna be kidding me he takes
every single one or the record-breaking
goat who makes
everything
look so
simple oh simple with the off got the
first one more close-up oh of course he
has that as well and at a third that is
spectacular but when it comes to what is
sometimes considered the crispiest
craziest op clinic ever administered on
the big stage
it's none of the usual suspects who can
claim ownership it's actually this guy
noah nifty francis a lesser-known
highlight machine who wrote his name
into cs go history by dropping more than
50 frags over the course of a single map
at iem sydney 2018. get the timing there
and now it's again nifty let's see what
he can do
for that rotation to come across and
nifty keeping them in this map we'll
spot out the final player as well and
two massive rounds
all right let's see some more magic my
friend with that orb chris j goes down
and nifty is coming up absolutely
so how is it that a relatively
lesser-known opera ended up putting on
one of csgo's most iconic performances
why don't we hear more about him these
days and after he put on a show like
that does it even
matter that we don't still hasn't
spotted anyone out just yet but oscar
will go down nifty again
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys so before we get into the
nifty 50 i am going to ask that you
please like the video subscribe to the
channel and
you know bunny hop your way over to the
notifications and enable them
thank you
i don't have anything man i don't know
okay so as of today nifty assigned to
team envy but has been inactive since
january of this year now whether or not
his cs go career will take off again is
a big question mark at this point but
that just gives him more time to focus
on his other loves like slapping
together fresh fits so for our listeners
he's wearing uh a guess sweater that
probably costs a crew neck sweatshirt
over 200 um and slinging dried meat
excuse me
but we're not here to dissect nifty's
uncertain present
no we are here to relive
his glorious past nifty's journey into
professional esports actually began at
the age of 15 playing call of duty where
he first made waves on the scene at umg
atlanta back in 2013. nifty last alive
and i gotta do it
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
despite officially joining conquer after
that event the team disintegrated just a
few short months later but nifty
rebounded the next year joining elevate
in a bigger role are you the captain of
elevate officially
yes i am i thought so and you should be
but it was around that same time that
nifty found his attention and time
shifting towards cs go citing certain
frustrations he had with activision's
series call of duty's change from year
to year so it just became a little stale
i kind of lost my love for it eventually
nifty made the switch to counter-strike
and spent about a year as part of
various time cs go rosters before
landing on selfless gaming where he got
to step into the spotlight at e-league
season one nifty can he go for a quick
shot here's a bit out of the open he
sees the feet there's one another one
would have got the kill but
rpk cancelling the path for a moment and
nice shot from nifty him just close the
lines mitch and oh nifty though moves in
he might say this one two three looking
for the fourth in range he's gonna get
it and now all of a sudden it's just
down to jdm nifty what an incredible
play they're defusing the bomb it's a
full 10 second a fuse though jdm's
peeking out he's trying to get the kill
the body block when he gets it and now
no
jdm saves it for team liquid now
unfortunately for nifty selfless
performance
wasn't a particularly memorable one and
after they bombed out of the event in
groups he and his teammates swiftly
received the axe but luckily for nifty a
new opportunity presented itself
diananda renegades recognized his
potential and offered him the chance to
become both their primary author and an
honorary australian and as nifty told
htc gaming he was optimistic about the
chance i feel like it's definitely like
a future you know that that can that can
set us up for great success and that's
something that i believe in and i think
all my teammates believe in as well so
um
we're going to do very well even though
nifty was technically moving up in the
cs world outside of smaller tournaments
like the asia minor and the star ladder
eye league invitational renegades were
struggling for consistency but in spite
of the team's at times woeful results
nifty occasionally reminded everyone why
renegades wasn't to be overlooked the
kill pop up in the feed
but he will have another crack
at a shot and this time he does deliver
oh nifty
that is disgusting and look where the
bombs drop now as well but he's landed
the scout shot now this round is back oh
what the hell was that
that is not how trigonometry works to
bounce the flash out the doorway it has
such nifty as full vision fires back
into seized just gets one on to jks but
nifty doubles up on the awp and he's got
a chance to line up more because he's
got perfect position back in the sight
simple down as well and nifty jumps back
above four kills for the young man don't
leave themselves enough time to get the
plan there we go first player drop nifty
ready to take more of a battle he's
still helping it out but he's dead now
however nifty still distracting moving
in he's wasting the fight they're not
getting that point it's just shot midair
as he takes out kusta nifty was clearly
talented and while he'd shown it in
glimpses it was at iem sydney in 2018
that he would reveal to everyone what he
was truly capable of now heading into
the event it was anything but business
as usual for renegades while
expectations weren't very high for them
the fact that they were playing in front
of their home crowd gave them an added
determination to put on a good showing
and after making it into the playoffs
through the lower bracket of their group
they were slotted to face off against
mousesports an in-form team who were
heavy favorites to move deeper into the
tournament the first map mirage went
basically how you expect with mouse
taking it convincingly 16-7 map two was
inferno and despite being renegades pick
it wasn't going much better than the
first and robs will shut down too nifty
doing his best shot on off impression
but again overwhelmed by the numbers of
mousesports and they are up to 10. with
their backs against the wall and their
tournament lives on the line renegades
needed to change the momentum of the
series they couldn't go out in front of
their home crowd with a whimper they had
to go down fighting and thanks to some
tactical mix-ups and excellent teamwork
the aussie outfit were able to claw
their way back into the game well they
do need to stop the rot because
renegades are certainly coming back into
this match and nifty now
taking matters into his own hands will
open up onto rops
not quite enough though for jacob to
rotate back across to the a bomb side as
we have seen previously so now just
three players
shut out from nifty that opens things up
nicely for the renegades as it's
starting to hit his shots as well
there's two players to deal with here
though and oscar has been dangerous but
as up is even more as he gets all three
massive work
as frustrated as they were mouse weren't
going to be vanquished that easily and
after making some adjustments of their
own they reasserted their advantage
putting renegades on the ropes yet again
i can't really afford to be losing any
more rounds now that all their chances
are done
this is the last opportunity for
renegades to come back into this map and
that my friends
is when nifty
lost his
mind nifty gets a connection onto chris
j and steps up against oscar as well oh
nifty he's bringing out the goods
but they must wait for that rotation to
come across and nifty the hero right now
for the renegades keeping them in this
map will spot out the final player as
well in two massive rounds
still more needed for ustillow and nifty
now as rox goes down and just one player
left to find stigma he'll drop that's
over time renegades have done it and
they still survive here on inferno
nifty needs to continue his form on here
right now he has been
the leader for renegades in more ways
than one
in the fast banana play front renegade
nicki's gonna be given the first and
nifty opens up onto sticker they might
have just timed themselves out of this
round
nifty is continuing to do damage the
molly under the bomb will seal it even
if all the kills come through there is
nothing that now sports can do spurred
on by their american operas heroics
renegades reached deep to force a third
overtime but even with the pressure
further mounting
nifty continued to just put on a clinic
both teams have been throwing absolutely
everything at each other look at this
what on earth nifty wow movement
and gets the incendiary down as well
denying the trade on the site let's see
some more magic my friend with that all
chris j goes down
and nifty is coming up absolutely
well nifty the man of the moment here
for the renegades will be
the first contact into the b-bomb site
smoke goes down late though there's a
hole in it
it's really not going to offer much for
nifty to work with and if he can find an
entry here
again again this man can do no wrong
nifty locking down the cet angle hasn't
spotted anyone out just yet but oscar
will go down nifty again
and it might just be the map two versus
one jacob and jks the two players from
the b site for renegades to close it out
sunny with
[Applause]
that's right after the dust had finally
settled on this grueling overtime war it
became clear that nifty had put on an
opping performance for the ages having
personally bagged an incredible 51
bodies that was well played i guess by
nifty i think bloody hell did pretty
good did that pretty good that's the
experience
is that all you've got janko perhaps you
can give me a little more nifty is a
gamer man isn't it what bunny hopping
melon popping bloodthirsty cs go deity
possessed nifty in that second half
we'll never know but what we do know is
that in spite of nifty's heroics on
inferno
renegades run at sydney came to an end
on train
and while it wasn't quite the fairy tale
ending the aussie fans would have wanted
nifty had dared them to dream
i just felt unstoppable you know
but it was a really fun series
mousesports was a great opponent so um i
mean i hope to play on more stages like
this you know this has been a dream this
is my first like real big stage so
um i loved it
the rounds that when i get renegades one
his statistics are perhaps the craziest
i've ever seen 45 excuse me 43 kills to
five deaths i'll keep going 152 adr 15
multi kills and eight opening kills in
the rounds they won on that map we
wouldn't have got to see that train we
wouldn't have got to see that over time
if it wasn't for that dude on that stage
nifty who now had a taste of the big
time continued to grace us with the
occasional nutty play here and there but
after a few disappointing team
performances that followed iem sydney
nifty returned back home and joined the
newly minted north american team envy
now at first he was off to a great start
and his sydney frag fest now known as
the nifty 50 was bringing him legions of
adoring fans people will never forget
how you made them feel so when it comes
to like fans and engagements and
interactions like that it's like that's
something that i just love because
uh they're i know how excited they are
to like you know meet me you know and
it's like i want to fulfill that
excitement and make sure that they do
remember that interaction because
any of these people could be something
crazy like one day you know they could
be a player themselves but after a bit
of twitter drama with other n a rosters
and some inconsistent performances
oh see he's gonna have to just get that
bomb and try to prioritize plant he's
gonna stick this nifty's going in for
the knife but he's fine
that's a team flash now the no scope oh
one
shot nifty found himself on envy's bench
which he's been warming since january of
this year it's hard to say where nifty's
cs go career can go from here but like i
said earlier this isn't a sad story of
what could have been
no we're here to celebrate an
achievement a display of skill so beyond
the realm of normal pro play that it
continues to stand as one of the
greatest individual map performances in
cs go history and even if nifty never
does anything else of note in cs go
we'll always have sydney
and that one
fabled
50.
a lot of people uh a lot of people will
say that you know it's just me like hard
carrying the team but
after just about every round you know uh
at least three of my teammates were like
no you're just you're owning you know
just like keep going keep going so
you know without without the push from
them i probably wouldn't have been able
to do it as many times as i did so
put our hands together it was a
monstrous performance one of the best of
all time the whole team were amazing for
nifty and the rest of the renegades
what a guy alex what a guy
it's like if you're a real league
try-hard you're like ah what's it called
msi
you know like that matters right like
but it's just shitty that you wait one
calendar a year for one league of
legends tournament that matters
and it takes 16 weeks to unfold and it's
just results in some
western team crying as they get
three-owed by koreans